hey everyone welcome back to warlord
podcast i'm james marshall and i've got
a huge episode for you today but firstly
this episode is brought to you by the
waterlab merch yes we have restocked in
hats and hoodies which were by far the
most popular items so if you enjoy this
podcast go and be a lad by getting
yourself your own lead hat or hoodie and
it's as simple as heading over to
wadala.com also on that website there's
also discounts for mintwear suzon and
puresport cbd so go and make the most of
those discounts while they're there
anyway i've got a great guest for today
so let's get to it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay here we are now since day one i've
had an endless amount of requests to get
this led on and i wasn't sure if the day
was ever going to come on the field he's
known as one of the most destructive
players in world rugby having dominated
all levels including for teams such as
tasman marco the chiefs the highlanders
and of course on the international stage
with the all blacks but along with all
the highs there have also been plenty of
lows with the endless amount of injuries
he's had that have taken their toll and
has recently forced retirement and as
most of you guys will already know he is
an absolute lad he's one of the greats
it is the man himself liam squire
welcome squiddy she's hell of an intro
cheers mate
mate stoked to have you on like i said i
wasn't sure if this day was ever gonna
come i put the feelers out a while ago
but i wasn't sure if you're ever going
to be king but like stoked have you on
yeah no i think you caught me on a good
day uh a couple days ago so
now i thought why not yeah i've listened
to a few it's been bloody good oh mate
appreciate it but
mate you're officially retired now so
how does that feel yeah um oh i've
probably probably known for a couple
months that i was gonna retire yeah
unfortunately but yeah i thought i was
handling it pretty well but sort of
reality kicks in when you make it
official so it's probably been a weird
couple of days uh
yeah still
trying to get my head around it and uh
i guess sort of get on with life
outside of it but yeah should be all
good yeah so how how hard was the
decision you said you
you knew a while ago so talk me through
that process when did you know how did
you know yeah so um
sort of after that second
super rugby game i got a scan a couple
days after and it showed that the
little cartilage area that was um
damaged had damaged again so
um getting that straight away
my
my sort of chances were pretty slim when
that happened but
we sort of wanted to wait six seven
months uh
with a lot of rest and
um a few treatment
on it uh to see if it would heal but
um yeah sort of deep down i sort of had
that gut feeling that uh this was
probably going to be it
but um
yeah it wasn't saying it definitely took
lightly it was um i had a few uh words
off the doctor and and whatnot but um
yeah i was sort of looking for any sort
of treatment or surgery but yeah we're
pretty limited
and how is your body you mentioned your
knee but um i know you've had a heap of
injuries throughout your career how is
the whole body feeling in general um
pretty poor to be fair uh
especially down in dunedin two of these
cold cold mornings i um
yeah i struggled to get out of bed it's
really it's actually yeah i sort of joke
about it but um yeah the old hip and
knee is not too flashing in sort of a
sleep on one side on the shoulder that
bloody
feels a bit tender in the morning and
yeah it's sort of
yeah it is what it is
is time going to heal that or
is that just going to be the normal life
for you i think i might have to get used
to today but
i'm i'm considering moving somewhere a
bit warmer so
yeah i think the negan's cold has
probably
done me done me uh done you wrong but it
was the knee that is the reason you
can't really play again eh yeah yeah yes
that's the knee um
speaking to the surgeon uh when he told
me that you know we're sort of
we're probably gonna hang the boots up i
asked him if
i'd be able to go running and and do
that sort of stuff just to keep fit and
and sort of keep um active but yeah he's
strongly advised uh not to run on it
again so
that that was that was pretty tough as
well because you know you spend 12 years
playing footy uh running around every
day training and then
it's old oh you yes not to run again now
you now you're finished so
yeah that kind of sucked mate so what
that's no running ever yeah so oh he
said you know i wouldn't take up jogging
or you know like i could run up to
run somewhere like if it was like a if i
needed to but chase yeah i wouldn't yeah
if the dogs are bloody
so what are you up to now that footy's
done you're working yeah so i i was
quite lucky i um
so when i found out about my knee
earlier on that
i wasn't going to play super rugby um
i actually went over to andrew hall's
place for
about six months he sort of took me on
uh working there and that was real good
for me i reckon because
it sort of set me up for life after
footy i just you know i got a taste for
it as well as not having the pressure
off of needing to work full time and i
could just sort of do what what i needed
to do on the farm and he was awesome i
sort of
talked to him about what was going on
and he um yeah he's full of full of
wisdom and you know he's obviously
been there done that so
i think that was really good for me i
was quite lucky in in that way
and is that what you're looking to do um
from now on yeah i thought at the moment
yeah i'm
farming down here and working on a
couple of different stations doing
casual but
yeah i sort of
made a
decision that i would probably move out
of dunedin so
um most likely ending up in nelson but
if that's uh farming or
working in the forestry i'm not too sure
yet um
nelson's sort of not really too renowned
for farming so
yeah i'll just sort of plat by yeah but
um yeah and how's the body hold up
farming or doing this harder work i'm
guessing it's hard yeah oh yeah you do
get some days where we're a bit sore
limping around especially if you do a
lot of walking
um on the hills and that but yes there's
definitely nowhere near up up with the
rugby side of things but
you do start to start to feel it and how
are you sort of feeling mentally around
the whole decision to finish rugby yeah
do you feel like you're going to miss it
or you're also a little bit excited to
not have to put yourself through your
body through all this pain again well at
the sort of start i was i was kind of
sort of happy kind of looking forward to
it because i was quite pissed off and
that i was injured again and
i was back to sort of square one but
now it's sort of been done and i know
that i won't play again um
yeah it's pretty disappointing and
i guess a little bit angry about it but
um
i'm just just still trying to get used
to use the idea of actually
you know i'm not going to
put on that highlanders jersey or all
that again so
yeah
still trying to get my head around it
yeah because you love rugby you love the
collision aspect of it you can tell that
but there's also parts of rugby that you
weren't a massive fan of were you like
that being in the spotlight you're
you're a guy who likes to be
up in the bush and away from it all is
probably a fair way to put it
yeah yeah that was something i i um
i really struggled with i didn't really
i can't probably wasn't prepared for
um i guess in a way that that sort of
fame that comes with sort of getting
into the all blacks and there and i
never really got used to it and it was
pretty uncomfortable to be fair so
um yeah that's definitely one thing i
won't miss i sort of
you know going back and just becoming uh
your sort of average joe back into the
normal public will be pretty pretty good
oh i'm looking forward to that
you'll be loving that
oh mate that's good stuff but anyway i
remember you coming to um tasman as a i
think you must have been like a 19 year
old guy so i pretty much know your story
from then on but i don't know much about
what your life was like before then so
give us a rundown on what your life was
like growing up yeah um
i grew up in palmerston north i'd um
three older brothers so
uh that was a
pretty
pretty fun upbringing yeah um being the
youngest in all yeah so i did i spent
most of my
well obviously until i was 18 19 and
palmerston off went to school
at palmy boys for
all of uh two years and um
i left the i lived there when i was 15
and went went dairy farming so
um
i don't really get along too well with
school
and all that so
we went down it went down to sort of a
different path yeah gave it gave up
rugby once i left school and
um yeah probably sort of took a few
wrong turns but yeah that was all good
what was what was it about school that
you didn't um relate to
um
probably a few disagreements with
teachers uh
i was quite a stubborn kid but um
oh yeah i don't know i just sort of
i i just didn't really like it it just
didn't get along and at the time because
i was only 15
and the age to leave was 16 we come up
with an agreement with palmy boys to
actually give me an exemption to leave
um so they sort of encouraged it and i
was all for it and
probably better for them that i left
after after about sort of six months i
was like
was that the right decision but so i
actually tried to
apply to go to um
to fielding ag
and then but i got denied so that was it
and were you good at rugby at this age
was that any reason to start school now
oh i didn't i didn't take it seriously
yeah like through um age group like
under 11s under 13s and
and that i played for manor too but
sort of when i got to boys high
i did trial for things like the under 14
colts which is the top team and i missed
out on that and it's sort of sad sad me
with rugby because
it was almost like it was like who you
know not what you know there yeah um so
i ended up playing
i think it was
maybe like under 45s kgs so
and it was like a b or c team yeah i
think we went the whole year without him
winning a game and i think
we would have scored less than five
tries the whole season
but it was fun though it was yeah it was
quite cool
so then how did you go from that
position to
eventually getting back into rugby um
i was i went working as an engineer so i
was about
16 17 by now obviously he was about 17.
so i didn't play for a good couple years
and then um i joined a club so when i
was engineering uh the other worker
there his old man um was the manager of
the marist cults old boys marist cults
and um he encouraged me to come along
and start training with them and so i
linked up with him and and um played one
or two
two or three seasons with them
sort of on on and off you know obviously
with club footy and working
you sort of play when you can and
um it was actually quite bizarre i ended
up playing against
palmy boys so i was playing against you
know the guys i went to school with in
the same age group and that so
yeah that was that was good fun but um
yes i did cultural
two three years
uh there which was quite it was real
cool and then how did the move down to
tasman come about is this when you
started to think that you might take
rugby a bit more seriously um no it was
it was sort of encouraged probably by my
mum that
uh i wasn't sort of doing two flash and
palmy it was sort of
um it's sort of at a dead end to be fair
i i just had surgery on my back
that was from a rugby injury you broke
it didn't yeah well yeah had a small
fracture in my l4 but that was because i
was about i would have been 75 kgs max
and i remember playing in the i think it
was senior a's and i looked i just ran
as hard as i could at their number seven
who was he was a big bouncer at the
night one of the good night clubs in
town his name's um
wonga i think his name was tonga
and um
i just got fold today
[ __ ]
i've never done that again
you did do that again you did it almost
every carry
oh no you just obviously put on a bit
more weight yeah yeah either way i
didn't have any weight and he just yeah
i stopped at a at a rate of knot so so
yeah that was a good learning curve and
that was a pretty bad break yeah
was there a chance that you might not
have been able to play again yeah they
sort of advised not not to sort of push
it and play again but i spoke to a lot
of once i got to nelson after that i was
about 19 when i when i ended up moving
to nelson
and um went to the physios there and and
we've done a lot of uh a lot of work to
try and get a lot of strength in my back
sort of back up and running was cut
which worked out real well and probably
ever since then so it was about
i was 19 when i got that surgery
right through till now i haven't had any
issue with it whatsoever so
that's been quite pleasing the one part
of your body that's still going strong
yeah yeah the
big screw in it um yeah it's still still
holding me up well
and then talk about your transition down
to nelson obviously i remember
you being a very explosive talented uh
rangy loose ford carved up the club
scene as soon as you came down and maybe
took one or two years before you ended
up becoming a big part of that tasman
side yeah so i was yeah i was 19 and i
started playing for
marist um senior ace and
my first year there
we had a stack team a we had like um
lucky molopolo
i think it was jimmy proctor and that
yeah and um we ended up we we ended up
winning that that uh that year which was
awesome and yeah i was quite lucky
enough actually to make
the marcos that year which was 2011 and
yeah that was sort of where it all sort
of started
and we were like that was the year as
well that tasman and southland and that
were they were trying to get us sort of
relegated and that so
still didn't know what was sort of
happening with tasman at the time but
like yeah being been in that environment
was awesome especially only being 19 and
in a semi-professional uh was quite cool
and you're a big part of the whole
turnaround of tasman like you said that
side that they were trying to get rid of
and
to see where they are now coming off two
championships i mean just the whole
turnaround of that tasman provincial
union has been massive and you're a big
part of that yeah it's it's awesome to
see i i remember
yeah and then that 2011 like we i think
we won two games and
we just we were battlers but like we had
a lot of fun yeah and then
i think it might have been in 2012 we
even
come close to winning the the rand
philly shield
and we and we started to improve then
yeah
and um but we started to get some some
good players coming coming to nelson and
then from then on each year uh we've
grown which has been real awesome and
you know you look at it now the amount
of super rugby players and all blacks
that are in there is pretty awesome and
like when i first started i think we had
two which was uh quinton mcdonald and
joe wheeler so um yeah it's pretty
awesome mate it is cool and then you
gotta sniff it super rugby with the
chiefs how did that one come about yeah
it was
i think that was
2013. i ended up signing with the chiefs
i was sort of i was halfway through
mitre 10 and
didn't really know where or if if i was
going to play super rugby but it was
something guy
i was aiming for but i actually got
approached by the western force
um before that oh yeah speaking of my
manager at the time like we talked about
a lot of things like um you know going
higher higher honors like all blacks and
and you know if i spent three years in
uh australia i could apply for
citizenship and
and like you know he did the pros and
cons and in a way was talking me out of
staying in new zealand just said that
you know there's a lot of um
a lot of good players lining up to
to get to that higher level of the all
blacks and steering me towards yeah go
in australia
luckily luckily i um
yeah luckily i turned down um and signed
with the chiefs so
yeah that that was awesome and quite
exciting and then how was it up at the
chiefs i know um wapa's said on his
podcast he was obviously living with you
and my brother and sounded like you guys
had a hell of a time together but how
was at your times up there at the chiefs
yeah it was awesome like i remember
around the first
first second day being in there like the
likes of um leah messim
um benafiyaki and all that were were
there and
like you remember watching them on tv
for years and idolising them and and all
of a sudden you you're training with
them and that which was real cool and
and like brodie retellic and sam kane
were um young all blacks there as well
so yeah yeah that was real cool
um definitely enjoyed that and living
with your brother and um whopper that
was uh
never a dull moment um
i don't think whopper's hygiene has
changed at all so pretty untidy
yeah what does big waffle like to live
with
he said a few stories about you but i
could imagine he would be pretty tough
work oh it was like we'd get to like
nine o'clock at night and watching tv
and then me and tojo be like oh we're
going to beard and it'll honestly be
like a 10 year old kid you'd think no no
stay up
don't don't go to bed yet and he'd bring
his mattress into the lounge
sit there and just want us to watch tv
the whole night with him just didn't
didn't like being alone in there
he pretty much lived in that lounge
just sat in front of that tv and watched
code
we'd have to watch uh
i think it was 2011 2012
clips of southland scrums with him
because he's put them on as my sky and
downloaded it all
painful
[Music]
oh that's classic
and what about on the field at the
chiefs um yeah that was that was kawaii
i remember it was
yeah my first year i played a lot more
games than i thought and really enjoyed
it um especially playing alongside
those those guys that yeah that you've
been watching on tv and and being a
first year um super ugly player
but you know any opportunity to play out
there was was something you took um with
both hands so
but it was also daunting at the same
time
that's a huge step up from mitre 10 and
um you know being been a young fella in
your first year it's yeah but like loved
it at the same time did you feel really
mentally getting a crack at that level i
don't really know for what was the sort
of expected or sort of what what come
with the territory of of being a
professional rugby player yeah because
like for me i obviously didn't play any
uh age group rugby for new zealand or i
wasn't sort of guided for an academy
when i was when i was young i spent you
know i was 19 when i first went into
tasman's academy
but i never really
sort of had that that normal pathway
that um
most of the rugby players have now yeah
um like i never played first 15 or or
any of that so
um that was a massive sort of uh sort of
a wake-up call and yeah it's it's hard
to it is hard to prepare yourself for
what is to be expected especially like
we do get um advice on
how to how to deal with situations and
that but
you know no one gives you the you know
the script for for what actually does
has come your way so
um you're just trying to prepare
yourself as much as you can for it but
at the same time you've just got to
yeah take it as it comes what are the
hardest things you have to deal with you
think um for me it's sort of the outside
noise
um
and especially the higher higher you go
uh
like you're always under the microscope
and i thought
obviously you know that that does come
with being being an all black but
i never got used to it and i was never
never comfortable with it but
um yeah that was challenging and
like oh you know you do get criticized
if you have a bad game and and whatnot
but for me
like i i knew i could
you know handle someone you know
roasting me on on social media or
something but it was more
uh
the effect it had on my family that was
the sort of uh
the main one for me and that that really
sort of pissed me off at a few times so
i wanted to protect them as much as i
could but
you know you can't really control what
what some people say or or do
so were you you weren't a big social
media man though either were you no no i
never really got into it and i still
can't really get into it it's yeah we do
we do get talked about uh
creating your own brand and whatnot but
yeah um yeah i've given up on
just the real big
the big key point
yeah
just the heavy hitter
yeah so then what what brought the move
about down to the highlanders
i i didn't really enjoy living in
hamilton to be fair i uh
too many late nights
living with him just
poisoned me pretty much it was just too
much i had to get away from her mate
[Laughter]
now i i because i'd obviously moved to
nelson and i've never lived in the south
island yeah um you know i pretty much i
fell in love with
with the south island and and
the people there so
um
i saw i approached the chiefs and said
look you know i'm keen to stay down
south and
and move this opportunity down and
the highlanders went back and forth
talking talking to them and
finally came to an agreement that i
would go down so
and and i i knew that that decision was
the best for me um especially with rugby
so and i i knew i had to had to make
that choice so i
fought for the better of myself so
um yeah i'm glad i did and you know it's
been awesome ever since i i come down to
dunedin and you weren't wrong because
your form just went to a whole nother
level down there at highlanders well
yeah i think the environment here sort
of allows players to do it and
you know it's it's like we get a lot of
players here that are
scattered from all around new zealand
and that and we we sort of sort of see
ourselves as being those the outcasts
that that no one really wants
but um for some reason that that's what
works when when everyone gets down here
and we have we have a lot of fun um
dunedin's an awesome place to to live
and
a lot of things to do so
the the team culture sort of just
produces itself uh in this environment
and straight away from as soon as you
went down there i think the following
year you got your all blacks call up how
was that one yeah so i think
yeah well that was 2016 i i actually i
actually played a trial game for them in
in
2015 i think
you you get called up to play game of
two halves it was me and shane christie
and um we literally flew we flew in
to north harbor
uh that morning
did a team training played played that
game that night and then
six seven o'clock in that morning we
flew back to our provincial teams and
we're just we just we were used as a
number just for them to have a hit out
because
the crusaders had just
uh won the super rugby so they were
resting yeah and um and that so but by
that that was an awesome experience i it
was
you know it was sort of chucked in the
deep end there they were yelling at
calls i had no idea but it just
went with it did after that did you feel
like you were up to that level to be an
international um not really no it was i
mean i remember literally going to my
first ruck and i think it was
ben frank's come in and just absolutely
annihilated the guy that was there and i
was i was just next to him and i was
like holy [ __ ]
i did not want to be on the other end of
that so
that that that was a huge wake up like
to say you know this is the level that
you've got to be at and the physicality
of it so
that was awesome to have a bit of a
taste of that i'm glad it wasn't me on
the run
so how did you get so physical because i
mean
you are known for your physicality you
throw your body into everything i mean
every time you go out on that field
you're you're just fully into it so how
did you get that sort of reckless regard
for your body um yeah i don't really
know i i've sort of been asked about it
a few times but
i guess it's sort of a
mindset that i go into a game like
um other players have got their own ways
of how they
sort of go out to try and inspire their
teammates and that and
i sort of figured out what works in a
way best for me sometimes it
doesn't go as planned but
um and it was a style that i i enjoyed
it sort of sort of gave me a quite a
good feeling uh when out there on the
field if i could play play that style
and i i really enjoyed it
that physical battle
i just you know when you're sort of
going head-to-head with a another player
um
it's pretty you know you can either go
one way or the other so
it's exciting challenge for yourself to
to try and sort of dominate each time
and
yeah i just enjoyed it so what was your
mindset going into a hard carry or a big
tackle um
i guess if it was a carry it was
probably the same as a tackle but i just
wanted to to
to run into as hard as i could i
wouldn't really worry too much about
technique at the time
it was just
i sort of knew
if if i could sort of hit someone as
hard as i possibly can each time
that i'd
most likely win the contacts so
um
yeah it was sort of
sometimes i should have used footwork
but um
yeah it was it was it was fun though and
i quite like having that fever getting
folded or or um getting gain lines yeah
yeah did did your mindset ever change
with the endless amount of injuries like
did it get to a point where you started
thinking
maybe i
i shouldn't be running into this one
quite so hard
yeah i
i had i had a few people sort of suggest
maybe to
to sort of ease into it i um
and just try and pace myself but
yeah i'm sort of either all in or not um
kind of a person and
i i did think about you know trying to
play a different style and and
sort of try and reserve my body in that
but
that wouldn't have really sit too well
with me i guess i i sort of pride myself
on on being a physical player and that's
what i really love about rugby so i
think if i went away from that um
you know i'll be sort of taking a
backwards step but
yeah
maybe i should have
oh that's good stuff anyway back to your
all blacks call up how did you get your
call up
uh
we just got back
to back to dunedin i think we were
playing
up in wellington and we were having a
two week break so it was the
international break and i i actually
thought you know i wasn't going to make
it so i'd planned
to head away the next day
on a hunting trip and i had a mate
coming down
to join me and he's bringing a bringing
a dog for me as well
and um
like yes i was actually i was actually
in mcdonald's drive-through because
you know what it's like after a
day after a game and you
been been flying back to yeah um your
your hometown and
and
unpacking and all that so
i went there and then i think it was um
shandy rung and i was like because you
know obviously the players had talked
about it
a few days prior like who who would make
it and whatnot and
i think it was shane christie was
messaging me every half an hour asking
if i'd been called and
i was like
nah they're not going to call us
sort of
humming and hiring if like you wanted
them to yeah and uh
but yeah he rang anyway and said and
said um congratulations and i was like i
was cause i was thinking you know my
mate coming down and all that and
obviously i've got dogs that need looked
after i was like
when do you want us to fly and he's like
oh seven o'clock and i'm like oh yeah in
the morning he's like no no that night
i'm like
i feel like so i was always going to say
oh
can i fly in the morning but i was just
shut my mouth and said yep
good as i'll be there
you're like the first person to ever be
slightly gathered to be called into the
all blacks
yeah it was yeah i just seen i just had
to sort a lot of stuff out before i
could actually go so
yeah and then what was it like once you
were up there um
yeah that that was probably your first
taste of sort of the limelight that all
that's get put in i remember because we
flew up that night it was me
ben smith and aaron smith
uh that went up and obviously they were
somewhat
late that there was two or three new
players being selected
and um we went out for dinner that night
and didn't really know that we were
going to bump into
because obviously the new all the news
reporters were up in auckland as well
because because of the press conference
the next day and we went out for dinner
and i remember walking past and and they
were all
out having dinner as well and i'm there
with ben smith and aaron smith
um
so like you know it doesn't take a
rocket scientist
um two and two to give her that that i
was selected and i think within half an
hour someone had leaked um not that i
was in but
they knew that there was a
bolter that's uh being selected so
um yeah that was that was quite funny
but that was yeah it was good and how
did you find the whole media side of
becoming an all black obviously once you
first name you probably have to do
thousands of interviews and all that
sort of carry-on photo shoots and all
that how did you find it
yeah i found it it was pretty
uncomfortable i i had i it was
when i was growing that uh mullet too so
that's all they were asking about and if
i was going to cut it and yeah or
whatnot so i was um yeah i it was quite
long at that time too i hadn't planned
for
any photo shoot or or anything so
um yeah that was that was quite full-on
it was i remember we did a whole day of
it and i was just exhausted i was like
[ __ ] i'd rather get into
the training camp rather than doing this
you were before your time with the
mallets too hey now everyone's got
though yeah everyone sort of
jumped on board now i remember when i
had it people were like oh what are you
growing that for
all this and that now it's sort of
you know if you don't have one you look
the odd one out
you made it cool again i remember some
some some lady wrote online and said
oh she was like
she was like he's a disgrace to the all
blacks and shouldn't have the mullet and
and all that and i was just like
they cut me deep
he needs to go to the barbell straight
away
you can bag me but not my mullet
never bagged the mullet yeah
yeah have a go at me but not not not the
mullet yeah
mate i guess that was the whole part of
it for the all blacks thing that was
probably the hardest day all that sort
of public scrutiny that you had to go
through even comments like that i mean
might not seem like much but they all
add up and they all do affect you right
yeah no no they do like
um obviously you try and joke about it
and that but
um
like i said earlier we do get put under
the spotlight a lot and
um
you know it only takes sort of one bad
game or a little bit of drop off on form
and
and you just get absolutely sort of
roasted online and it's
yeah it's not nice um
uh yeah especially when you're when
you're on the receiving end of it um
like we do have um
a lot of
sort of training in that to deal with it
but
deep down you get you you can do all you
can but um
yeah if if you do read it and that it
does
you know we're only human so it does
affect us
yeah did you ever find something that
did sort of help you with that um
probably just not reading it yeah yeah
which is
like i talked to
someone about it i think it might have
been
um crud's aaron cruden and he said
if you if you can't read the bad stuff
about you don't don't just read the good
stuff
so um that's sort of like you know
because most you know most players like
if they know they've had a good game
they they read the approach and that you
know it's sort of a feel-good thing but
if you're just willing to read that but
not the bad stuff um you shouldn't
really read it at all this was his way
of doing it and i i find that i found
his way
um quite inspiring to be fair like he he
was off social media didn't read him
into any of it and um yeah he was real
real strict on it which was quite
impressive it was pretty cool and there
was a game where you really stamped your
mark as a international loose forward i
guess and it was that 57 nil drubbing of
south africa were you absolutely
intimidated a south african ford pack
like i'd never seen someone do talk me
through that game for you personally um
yeah that was like honestly playing
south africa like i've got tons of load
of respect for for them and i like i
love the way they they all play like
they are they're big men and they
they fly into contact and um
so i
leading into those games you you know it
doesn't take much to to get up for
that battle that you're gonna
you're gonna go forward with them and
like they were probably up there with my
favorite games as playing south africa
because you knew
you knew what it was going to be like
and you know it never never failed like
obviously we we scored a lot of points
and
and that but it definitely didn't take
away how how physical and how tough um
opponents they are
did you take confidence after that
because like you say south africa are
known for their physicality they are the
most physical side in the world they're
matt they've got a massive pack who do
like you say love to hit hard and those
couple of games make you match them and
probably win at them um yeah i probably
never got that sort of feeling of
feeling that confident in the um all the
extra it was it was quite weird i put a
lot of a lot of pressure on on myself
and and the way i played and which was
uh a little bit of a downfall on my side
of things but
um
yeah it's something that if i could have
gone back and and changed i definitely
would off but
i had i had massive uh expectations on
how i wanted to play and
i never really got sort of too
comfortable
in it which yeah and in a way like you
do want you you do want sort of a good
balance of confidence but also being on
edge as well but
um i think i was on edge most of the
time so
it was it wasn't that fun to be here
well was that just like so super
stressful like were you stressed out in
meetings and trainings and was it the
whole sort of week that you were feeling
that yeah yeah without a doubt i i
like i
it would start on on monday like we
would um
have obviously have our review
and then we'd get given
our line outs for the week and
i would i would spend all night learning
these new moves um
going for all the scenarios of of the
line outs and that
but like i could never
get it down packed like
i struggled massively like
yeah i've been pretty lucky with the
coaches i've had because obviously i i'm
dyslexic so
um
all that sort of learning with the
writing and reading and that was real
real tough but
um
that they helped me out massively with
it but i still
uh it was something that i was real real
conscious of that i really need to nail
but it wouldn't have been until i'd say
friday
leading into the game where i knew i had
had the line outs or something sorted
but i used to be on i was on edge that
whole the whole week and i get to the
day off and i literally would just have
to
pretty much sleep all day because i was
just knackered oh
geez that is intense and
did you find a way to
speed up your learning process being
dyslexic did you find a process for
yourself that made it easier eventually
um yeah i think the main sort of
learning for me was actually
telling obviously the coach at the time
or the ford coach or whatever
um what what how i learned and the
difference that i had with um other
people
like you know i'm obviously a person
that um has to has to do the
movement or whatever physically to learn
it
so um
like one and once they got on board with
that and they knew obviously i was
dyslexic they were awesome a lot they
didn't they didn't see it as a weakness
or anything they were they were great
about it and um
sort of gave me the confidence that
you know that i could do it but
the in that environment in the all backs
because
the line outs and that team is like the
da vinci code
um
broder italic was
probably
you know my um
savior and that side i think on monday
nights we'd spend a good hour going
through them in the team room and then
meet up again on in the morning and do
them for another 15 minutes so
um
yeah that was awesome you know having
having guys like that to help you out
did you feel like going into a game you
were still worrying about the calls and
stuff or
by the time you got to a game were you
always did you always just let that go
and then just play um no i was i was
still worried
that bus trip uh to the to the grounds
was they were probably the most daunting
bus rides i've ever had a because i was
covering uh six and number eight which
is really number eight was rido's
position and he had every single
movement in the line out
um
yeah
it was tough and
but i i found once i sort of got out
there on the field you know it actually
it did
come sort of naturally and and your
natural ones things sort of kick in
which was good and you knew you know
that stuff you did during the week um
sort of allowed you to be able to do
that button yeah
and then obviously in 2019
leading up to the rugby world cup you
made the decision that you weren't going
to
be available for selection for that so
that was obviously a extremely tough
decision but a very brave decision and i
guess sort of what you've spoken about
already around how mentally draining
being involved in the all blacks was was
a big part of that decision
um
yeah i'd
yeah it was it was a lot of sort of
build up of um
probably
12 18 months of of um
rugby so i know i knew i just come off
that 2019 interview tour and i wasn't
sort of happy with how i'd played and
um
the sort of stuff i had in place wasn't
sort of what i needed like for me to
sort of be happy was was all on my
performance and
if my performance didn't sort of fill my
cup so to speak
um
i'd sort of beat myself up over it and
with the india tour we had a massive
eight-week break in between so
i spent eight weeks um stewing on on how
i was playing and
and
sort of being quite frustrated uh in a
way
but i knew you know if i sort of put
that into my training you know i could
use it as a positive so i remember
coming into 2019 and i was i was feeling
feeling quite good um physically
but then
yeah so in in pre-season i ended up
tearing my groin
a couple weeks into pre-season which is
a good classic for most players in
pre-season
good way to get out
[Laughter]
um but but i was yeah i was pretty
gutted at the same time because
i'd spend uh six weeks
uh rehabbing that and i i missed all the
preseason games but
i think i was due to play round two
of the um super rugby so i built into
full training and
you know what it's like on a thursday
training you go for a 40 45 minute um
full contact 15 on 15.
um and i was on the i was in the dds so
i was um running against the highlanders
at the time because i was still one week
away from playing yeah
and i remember
we were playing we were playing the
blues and obviously they had good
jacklers so
as a loose fort i was sort of contesting
the ball
uh at training and
just your typical prop uh comes diving
in on the side and and
caved my knee in which was
just sort of the icing on the cake so to
speak um
you know i was going to play the next
week and then and then so
i got a scan on that and uh i think it
was my mcl head torn so
ended up being
i think it was eight to ten weeks and
yeah i've never i've never been a good
player injured so i've always
i've never got used to it and i've never
really
mastered how to
how to sort of bounce back and and sort
of get back on track i
i'd spend weeks you know
angry about
what's happened and
you know obviously i couldn't do
anything about it but um
you know it was yeah it was something
that that i never got used to and
um
something that i yeah i wish i had
a better way to deal with it but
i just didn't really know what to do at
the time
is there anything you do differently now
knowing what you know
um
yeah i think you know like if you get
told you know say yeah yeah for six or
eight weeks or something you know
obviously obviously you're you're gutted
and you're you feel like you've let the
the boys down in there but
i think
best of a way is just uh of it you know
you can be a bit gutted but you've gotta
you've got to sort of shift your focus
on to um
on to what you can control next and
obviously that's
rehabbing yourself the best you can so
you can you can come back and play
quicker
um but that was yeah something i never
never really quite mastered um
throughout my time i probably shut off
with the amount of injuries i had that
you had that many yeah but it is it is a
crazy one it's something that you look
back on and it doesn't seem like a big
deal being injured for
four to six weeks or whatever it is and
you're still getting paid and all that
but
when you're in that moment man it's so
hard to
feel like that and look at it from that
perspective when you're in it yeah and
like
because of obviously
i wasn't happy with um how 2018 finished
and
i hadn't even got a chance to play
um a game
probably a good three quarters off the
super rugby
um and all that just sort of built up
and
like i i bottle everything up
uh
pretty much and i wasn't really talking
to too many people
at that time i sort of
um sort of took myself away from the
holland's environment and did my own
thing
at the time and
that that wasn't the best thing i
thought it was for me yeah just to be
away from the players because i
i'd go into
um hq and you'd see the boys and they'd
ask when you're back playing and all
that and i just every time you just you
felt like you let them down because yeah
you know you're um
you're not out there training with them
and
and whatnot so
um yeah that that was tough and
i i sort of i didn't get back to playing
in that 2019 until our second to last
round robin game
and um once i sort of got back into play
uh that i was going to be playing in
that all the
world cup stuff started uh
surfacing and
so a lot of people asking is he is he up
for it or was he ready because i've i've
missed a lot of rugby
and the main one was you know as is
going to go over there and get injured
and all that and
i just
yeah all that noise i was hearing and um
yeah it's just something that i
probably should have tried to
cut out
um but yeah i just
yeah didn't really know how to handle it
is that why you made that decision to
not make yourself available because you
were sort of sick of that noise or did
you genuinely not want to go there um so
originally it was
the rugby championship um that i told
steve that i wanted to stay out of yeah
um
and then
like i thought that was the best for
myself um obviously i'd only played
three games and
i played uh i think it was a
quarterfinal against the crusaders and
got yellow-carded and then
typical me looking into what the media
was saying uh you know they were going
what's he going to be like at the world
cup is he going to
get yellow carded in a semi-final or
something like that yeah and um
yeah that was sort of
quite frustrating to hear and
and whatnot so um and i didn't think it
was going to be a big deal at the time
uh to be left out i was sort of hoping
that they would just say i was out of
form
and uh
not selecting me but
yeah so the the plan was to go back to
um
tasman and just to play some rugby to
try and get my confidence back up but
yeah it was it was a tough one
and what was that what was it like once
you had made that decision and that had
been put out there how did you feel once
everyone was saying that you had made
yourself unavailable um
yeah it was it was quite a strange way
it actually worked out because
um i didn't really know what was going
on
uh at the time with selection or whatnot
but the media put out that i needed to
call steve i don't know if you remember
or not but
they were saying oh liam needs to call
them and i had no idea so i was learning
this stuff
when um
obviously the public was as well
so i sort of found that quite
frustrating because you know you're
finding out all the stuff through the
media
um which wasn't ideal but
uh yeah
it is what it is but
um
yeah well it wasn't ideal to to find out
that way that you needed to do that and
then obviously your next move was over
to japan with docomo why'd you make that
decision
um oh that that was before
i
pulled out of the world cup
at the time i think it was because i
talked to my agent quite a lot um we
sort of thought you know i was getting
to the air i think i was 28 and we
thought um if i went to a world cup and
ended two
maybe three years in japan and then
called it quits after that and that was
sort of um
the goal at the time
uh
but yeah so i ended up going over there
for a season and then
obviously an injury of my knee sort of
cut it short but also covered it as well
and um
yes
and in that time
of being back in new zealand uh
i sort of had a
change of heart with wanting to play
play in new zealand again and um and
give it a good crack here and you also
had a pretty major
surgery scare too wasn't it did you get
your hip and your knee done and one of
them became infected
um
yes i i had hip surgery
um
during the year
but it was about six weeks
six or eight weeks after that i'm not
too sure if it was due to my hip or not
but
i um
it was on a on a tuesday i think i i
started getting
uh quite a lot of pain in my left
shoulder as it sort of felt like i had a
dead arm and over sort of
48 hours it got
worse and worse where i actually
couldn't lift lift my arm up and i
remember getting home because i was
working on andrew's farm at the time
as well i remember getting home and i
need to have a shower i couldn't even
get my shirt off
and i didn't know what was going on and
i thought it was i thought it was just a
muscle
um in my in my neck so i went to the
doctors and they they thought yeah
you've you've got a tight knit muscle or
a shoulder muscle and that so
um
i went to the all blacks physio pete
and um we got we did a lot of
acupuncture in it yeah and tried to
release a lot of the muscles in there
and
he sort of realized at that time he was
like nuts it's got nothing to do with a
muscle
and that's so i went i went back home
and and sort of thought you know i'll
just park up and and see how it going i
was just getting worse and worse and a
lot of pain
and um
i was quite stubborn didn't really want
to go to hospital
um
this was about on a thursday
and um eventually a couple of friends of
mine took me into the urgent doctors in
in dunedin
and um it was my second visit there that
day so
they took me right in and took my
temperature and i think i was
my temperature was about 38
uh
at the time so
i didn't really know it but they'd rang
an ambulance and within
15 minutes i was i was rushed into
hospital
on on thursday night and what was it was
it an infection in your shoulder yeah so
um
i went into a ward and it was i think it
was friday by then and they were just
sort of
monitoring me seeing how how things were
going and i was just getting worse and
worse um each hour during the day
and
i got to one stage where like i i
couldn't really move that well and i was
hot and cold and the nurse come in and
i was actually waiting for an mri
um scan to see what was going on but
the mri machine in the hospital was
fully booked until
saturday afternoon
yeah
and i was i was there um no good and and
then so the nurse took my temperature
again and i think it was up past 40.
once that sort of happened that they
rushed me into
into the mri machine
um
and i was in that much pain i
i i'm pretty sure i passed out in the
machine because it was they they took
off all of um i was obviously on some
heavy painkillers there so they took
them off to put me in the mri machine
and
i was in no good estate i was bloody i
was yelling at the
the lady that was trying to move my arm
and i was
not good
um
yeah so you know it wasn't until after
that they
they took me back up to the room
and um when i got there
uh there was it was about six doctors
there waiting
i was like i was like this is not not
too flash
yeah it's not it's not good and mom had
turned up um
as well so yeah and that's when they
sort of
told me that
uh things weren't looking too good
jesus yeah initially they thought that
um
it was an infectious
flesh-eating disease oh yeah and so they
rushed me into theater
and i remember the um the guy that was
gonna put me under said
um well they warned me that that i was
gonna wake up and i see you and have
my whole chest open
um
and and he also said that
you know this is probably going to be
one of many surgeries
um
but i think i think yeah at the time
they
they actually
you know thought it was
it was quite quite sort of threatening
at the other time
um
which was quite scary but yeah they
didn't tell me until i sort of
went down to the theater
um and that's but like luckily i come
out of that surgery and and that
opened up my neck right across there
um
and and got some of the infection out
and just left the tube in there for a
week
to
let it drain out and we never really
figured out what was the cause of it um
but
yeah luckily we managed to
sort of come out on top so to speak
crazy did you fear for your life going
into that surgery did you genuinely
think you might not be waking up here
yeah it's sort of like i feel a little
bit silly now saying it but
um yeah i did at the time i
i sort of i actually made a few phone
calls i think i rang my dad um
and that just uh
um sort of talked to them and and that
because yeah there was that chance that
you know i was actually even going to be
quite sick
for a while or you know things were a
lot worse and and um head down the
wrong way so yeah that was pretty
daunting that's probably the
sort of most frightened i've ever been
yeah
you know sort of
take a bit of a scare like that to give
you a wake-up call and then obviously
rugby was the last thing on your mind at
this point yeah i was
yeah i was obviously back in dunedin and
wanting to um get back into the holland
but yeah i spent uh i think there's
eight or nine days in hospital and
like a lot of time to to think about
your choices that you've made and
and what you want to do with the rest of
your sort of time that i had and that
was probably a good sort of reflection
time for me
and and really sort of got the fire
burning again to actually want to get
healthy healthy was was the main thing
but also start playing rugby again um
in new zealand
so that was a big turning point and you
obviously did that you made your return
for the highlanders
hissing cameo straight back into the old
physical squire straight from the get-go
off the bench one of the great cameos
how did you feel running back out there
um yeah
that feeling of running out foresight
bar is
sort of second to none yeah uh
especially especially for the hollands
like yeah i loved playing at home and
um to to actually be back in new zealand
playing like i was i was on top of the
world and real excited for what was sort
of ahead and yeah obviously
um getting back into that physical side
especially when you
i think our first game was against the
crusaders which is my favorite team to
play
just which is awesome so yeah but then
it got cut short again with another
injury so
how was this one to deal with yeah this
is sort of it was tough i
was after the chiefs game and my knees
started sort of playing up again and
feeling like
it it was when i first injured it and
that's when i sort of
really sort of knew that you know this
wasn't too good um
it was sort of giving way
walking and that and i was real sort of
determined um not to
head down that path but yeah we we tried
all we could uh to get it right but
yeah unfortunately it wasn't meant to be
no absolute shame
career cut short at 30 when you still
had
so much more to give
but mate what an incredible journey geez
that's good to hear um [ __ ] there's some
insight into
some of that stuff that's happened in
your career but as always we've gone to
our instagram for some questions and
since you were the most requested guest
we've ever had to come on there was
heaps and heaps of questions
um so heaps of questions are about
hunting so
um how often did you go for a hunt
during your career that's the first
first question
um so most of the time
so we play on a saturday
i'd go for a hunt on a sunday
uh after a game
and
and our typical week we'd have a
wednesday off so usually i'd go for a
hunt on the wednesday so i could usually
get two in during the week if um if
things were going well wow that's crazy
was your body not ever too sore to
go out on a sunday oh i sort of found
that if i did go out and
and go for a go for a walk yeah um
obviously i didn't go do anything stupid
and go for a massive hike i i sort of
stayed close to the to the motorbike um
and that and hunted some places that
were that quite easy
it actually helped sort of rather than
sitting at home in front of the tv uh
and i talked to
my trainer glenn stewart about it a lot
about that sort of recovery and getting
that blood flow moving again and
um i i think that probably helped me
with a lot of my recovery and keeping
active
fair enough like that
um next one
best hunting story
this will be good oh that many hunts
you've been on
um
i don't know if this is this could be
the best or maybe the stupidest
um
it was actually not not too not too long
ago
actually probably three or four months
ago i
after work me andrew hoare and
the other worker we went out for a quick
hunt out the back and
um
they were looking after the bike so i
was
obviously running after or not running
but
going after the dogs
and they had a pig
at the time and i couldn't hear it so
i was being pretty casual about it and
didn't take
a rifle with me or a headlamp and
obviously it was getting dark
and uh
i i finally got to
where the dogs were and they had this
pig i remember getting in there and it
was dark
i could only just see
but as i went to go and grab it the dogs
actually let go
and on there
again it's just running straight at me
and like
i had to jump out of the way i mean to
put my hand out to push it off and i
just felt my hand go real warm
and at that time i realized my hands in
its mouth and its tusk went straight
through my
the middle of my sort of
hand
and the finger and and and ripped it
right open oh
i was like i remember i pulled my hand
out and
and sort of
uh
held my held my fingers together and i
didn't want to look but i opened up my
hand and there was just this deep hole
in between my fingers
in the in the middle of my hand wow and
i was like [ __ ] i was like i'm here by
myself
uh i've got no headlight and i've got to
get these dogs off so
i end up finally getting in there and
sorting it out but
um i'm rushing back to the bike
to
holding my hand together
and like we're probably a good hour from
home
um finally get back there and and
andrew's like real casual about it just
cruising and um
we have a bit of a laugh i'm probably
panicking a little bit at this stage
because i i couldn't really feel my
fingers at the time so i was like i've
done done damage here
and that so i finally finally go to
hospital um that night
and they actually
put me under the next morning to clean
it out
as dramatic as it sounds
they did that
oh it was not good i was back at work
the next day which was all good but
um yeah they cleaned it out and and
stitched it up and that was yeah so yeah
i'll take a headlamp next time
that is crazy you're lucky that wasn't
an incident or the recovery day hunts
oh that would not have been good i think
yeah i wouldn't have been able to play
for a couple weeks with that because it
was right in the way being off my
fingers so
yeah i don't think any of the coaches
would have been too happy
oh that's a good yarn okay next question
oh this is a good one thoughts on young
ethan blackadder and the comparison of
him with you
oh young doofy um
yeah he's the man i i've got um so much
time for
for ethernet i reckon he's yeah he'd be
one of my favorite rugby players uh at
the moment and
probably you know
a lot of people see all his um actions
on the field but this is the type of guy
he is off the field you know he's he's
an absolute lad like he'll do anything
for for anyone of his mates and um
you know he is definitely the type of
guy you want beside you
and um
he's and and you see the way he's
playing like well i think he should
probably be in that starting 15 every
week and that all blacks um i'll
definitely have him in in my team so
um
and the way way he plays and and that
like
i actually wish i was out there with him
he's outstanding right he is an absolute
champion eh yeah he's one of the great
okay next question what's better singing
the national anthem for the all blacks
or listening to your dog's barrel of
bore
um
it's a pretty special feeling um hearing
the dogs open up
it's the anticipation of finally finally
hearing them so
i'm probably going to have to go after
dogs bailing
[Laughter]
i genuinely thought you would
say that as well oh that's a good
question okay what's your favorite loose
ford trio you played alongside with oh
that's a great question um probably i
think sam kane and jerome cano
um
you know i've always looked up to to
jerome the way he plays and you know he
sort of took me under his wing coming
into the all blacks so
um
yeah that was awesome to play alongside
him and
and everyone knows the way sam kaine
plays and and how hard he can tackle and
and the engine he's got on him um
yeah
they're awesome players good answers
couple of absolute lads
okay next question
uh
what kept you motivated to go to
training every week um
i guess
probably for me as it's that feeling on
the field when you finally actually get
out there on on saturday and play
um alongside your mates
it's you know if you get things going
right it's it's pretty contagious and
and just just seeing your mates every
day um is is pretty awesome and you sort
of get a lot of energy from from being
around them and and going to battle with
them each week nice okay next one was it
true about the rumors of you signing
with southland um
i didn't sign but
yeah i was gonna go to southland
uh
the stags fans will be gutted that would
have been the ultimate signing for the
stacks you're in banksy
oh i was pr yeah i was pretty gutted i
didn't i get to get a chance to um
that's them ringing now um i didn't get
a chance to go uh play for them like
yeah it's definitely
um a team i i would have
really enjoyed to to be a part of yeah a
few good hunting spots down there i'd
imagine yeah yeah some great spots okay
where did the nickname dennis originate
from
um
this is a bit of a there's a bit of a
yarn behind it here we go um it was
actually me and your brother tom
marshall
we we both were both injured
we're both quite bad injuries at the
time and
the tasman marcus they brought in
um an intern trainer just to take me and
tom for our rehab
and um
he was an absolute lad like and his name
was dennis and
like we had some great times with dennis
he was
the funniest guy you'd make
he made he made
turning up to training and going to
rehab um that much better like
yeah that sucks not been able to train
but but dennis he uh
he boosted our morale every day
you should have got him to follow you
around
with your career yeah i i did think
about having him on and and let him live
with me and take him take him everywhere
i went
he's an absolutely still
living in nelson i think as a uh
swimming
lifeguard
moana pool so
yeah if you're listening dennis i hope
you're well right when you move up no
doubt you'll be catching back up with
him for sure i'll be linking up with
dennis
for dinner
no linking up
[Laughter]
okay
okay last question uh best piece of
advice you ever received in your career
oh
the heavy one
um
best piece of advice that i've had given
to me and also experienced is probably
um
just doing what what what suits you best
like you gotta you gotta put yourself
first um
um a lot of the time and i know you
don't wanna be selfish but there is
times where you've gotta put your best
interest um first and i think in rugby
and in life um
there's a lot of
uh sort of opportunities you'll get to
do that and
um
you know obviously you will probably
piss a couple of people off but as long
as as long as you're happy and you're
doing
doing what you feel is right i think you
sort of can't go wrong especially
um within yourself
mate that is a powerful way to finish
the podcast great advice i knew you'd
come up trump cheers mate
anyway danny absolute pleasure to get
you on the podcast jeez there's some
good stuff in there um like i said at
the start it was awesome to play with
you back in the early tasman days and
just see how far your careers progress
from those early days has been
awesome to watch and see see where you
are now
um unfortunately i know having to hang
up the boots but
your life is just getting started really
looking forward to seeing what you do
next in your in your future and mate
like i said at the start you're an
absolute lad so it's been awesome to
have you on the podcast yeah thank you
and um
just thank you to everyone for their chi
messages over the last few days it's uh
it's been pretty humbling um to to read
them and to hear them and
um yeah you know like it's pretty
awesome that we've got some great fans
here in new zealand and
yeah thank you mate you've had a massive
influence on so many guys careers
haven't yet because i even even reading
some of those posts everyone loves liam
squire and that's why so many people
message me every day trying to get you
on the podcast yeah i guess that's one
thing that probably
stood out for me reading a few of them
is that yeah i did make a few people
happy so that sort of filled my cup um a
fair bit and
um yeah i guess a little bit proud but
yeah
you can definitely be proud you've had a
hell of a career and you're a great man
appreciate you coming on mate thanks
mate appreciate it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what
[Music]